serbia begins its negotiations to join
the european union this month
kicking off years of talks aimed at
bringing thousands of pieces of national
law and legislation into line with EU
standards membership will bring greater
economic prosperity to serbia more
diversity to europe and could boost
stability in the Western Balkans which
was torn apart by war just two decades
ago to go fast with reforms internally
and also with negotiations we think that
it is real realistic to consider to
finish negotiations during this decade
the talks will focus on 35 chapters or
policy areas like the free movement of
goods and workers food safety justice
human rights and economic reform
chapters can be opened or closed in any
order at any time it's unclear how long
the process will take but Belgrade will
drive the pace based on its merits in
tackling some deep and far-reaching
reform we put fundamentals first that
means a huge attention on issues like
fundamental rights independence of
judiciary rule of law fight against
corruption fight against organized crime
so these are areas where we put a lot of
attention a lot of emphasis successive
waves of enlargement have seen the EU
grow from its original six founding
members to twenty eight currently the
prospect of joining the Union with its
economic and trade might has proved a
powerful force for reform particularly
in the Western Balkans apart from
adhering to EU technical and legal
standards Belgrade must maintain good
relations with Kosovo which declared
independence in 2008 relations with
Kosovo will remain important for Serbia
also in its accession process in the
negotiations it will have to continue to
push through agreements reach in the EU
facilitated dialogue and it will have to
continue to cooperate closely with the
EU rule of law mission in Kosovo which
we call elects the aim for this is that
both Serbia and Kosovo
advance on their path on their European
path without blocking each other
ultimately the accession process is no
guarantee that Serbia will be allowed to
join the European Commission must
regularly report on progress Belgrade
has made toward meeting the --use
membership criteria it will then
recommend whether Serbia should become
an EU member state only if every nation
agrees will the Balkans country be able
to take a seat alongside its European
Union partners